audiences will be cast back into the
fires of panm with The Hunger Games a
ballad of song birds and snakes here's
everything you can expect from the movie
from who starring through it fits into
the story fans haven't enjoyed a new
Hunger Games movie since the Hunger
Games McKing J part 2 hit theaters in
2015 thankfully they don't have much
longer to wait The Hunger Games a ballad
of song birds and snakes is set to debut
on November 17th 2023 it seems like a
long wait for fans of the franchise but
this movie has actually made a
relatively Speedy Journey to the big
screen the book it's based on Suzanne
Collins The Ballad of song birds and
snakes was released in 2020 thus a
pretty Swift turnaround between
publication and cinematic adaptation
even for a blogbuster franchise this
timeline is even more impressive when
you take the co 19 pandemic into account
the crisis hit me months before the book
was launched spoiling all hopes of real
world tours and events as the pandemic
ground on the movie's production
schedule was doubtlessly impacted yet
the powers that be still managed to get
it cast planned filmed edited and ready
to go in just a few years even the most
eager fans can appreciate that sort of
flexibility and determination in The
Ballad of song birds and snakes Grena
snow the fish desperate who menaces
catniss across all four original movies
is a young man with a massive weight on
his shoulders his family is crumbling
and he might be the only person who can
save it accomplishing this gets even
more difficult when he sent a mentor
District 12 female tribute to the 10th
annual Hunger Games Lucy grey bead a
gutsy musician she wants to win and her
Charisma might just help her achieve
this but the capital is as thorny as
ever and plenty of people would like to
see snow and Lucy burn new characters
like Casa High bottom architect of the
games and Dr volumnia Gaul head game
maker cast Long Shadows while ancestors
of figures were already familiar with
like lucky flickerman review just How
Deeply rooted panum's dysfunction truly
Tru is things got even more complex when
Snow's feelings for Lucy become deeper
and more urgent than simple mentorship
despite the appearance of some familiar
names producer Nina Jacobson described
the movie as an independent entity she
remarked at C Europe it's a new story
with new ground and new characters we
were able to create a completely
different visual language one that is
still recognizably panm but also
different and fresh it'll also be a
philosophically weighty tale Jacobson
mused to polygon are we fun Fally good
if left to our own devices are we
fundamentally bad and need the state to
keep us in check or we'll destroy each
other these ideas about how people
perceive each other and the government
and what they need based on those
perceptions felt so incredibly timely
see how quickly we become
Predator see how quickly civilization
disappears so who's playing these song
birds and snakes first and foremost Tom
blle will star as a young cor Elena snow
it'll doubtless he be interesting to see
how he fletches out the villain after
Donald Sutherland's commanding presence
in the first four Hunger Games movies
blle isn't hugely well known yet but
he's drummed up some birds of recent
projects like Billy the Kid and the HBO
period series the guilded age his
performance of snow is poised to launch
him into further Heights as for Lucy
grey bad she'll be played by Westside
Story and Shazam Fury of the god star
Rachel Ziggler she's already proved she
can handle emotional drama thanks to her
time working with Steven Spielberg on
the former musical while the latter
project show case to action potential
this is a perfect mix for a dauntless
and warm-hearted heroine like Lucy the
rest of the cast is just as impressive
celebrated Talent Peter Dinklage will
play Casa High bottom the complex brain
Behind The Hunger Games concept the
legendary Viola Davis will play Dr
volumnia G who gets the Hunger Games
well and truly rolling for her Sinister
minations Jason schwarzman will play
lucky flickerman ancestor to Stanley 2
che's Caesar flickerman many fans have
wondered if the stars of the first four
h ler Games movies will make an
appearance particularly Jennifer
Lawrence Watch What Happens Live host
Andy Cohen went ahead and addressed a
rumor she'll be popping up in the panm
of the past as catniss his grandma
Lawrence made it clear that she will not
no no that's not happening that's not
true tough luck catniss fans when fans
settle in to watch The Hunger Games a
ballad of song birds and snakes they
won't just be returning to a familiar
fictional landscape they'll be returning
to the work of a beloved director
Francis Lawrence who directed every
Hunger Games movie except the very first
will Helm the snow Centric prequel fans
know he's an expert when it comes to
this franchise his skillful inventive
and steady direction is a huge part of
what makes the original quartet work now
he's poised to take it back in time
Len's filmography isn't confined to panm
however movie goers first encountered
him through 2005's Constantine his first
feature more met him through 2007's I Am
Legend since he guided Katniss through
the revolution he's directed two more
movies the 2018 spy Thriller red Sparrow
and the 2022 family fantasy Slumberland
he's also set to Helman adaptation of
the acclaimed Bioshock video game series
Francis Lawrence isn't the only familiar
creative returning for the prequel
producer Nina Jacobson of the production
company Color Force has been producing
The Hunger Games film series since the
very beginning after reading the first
book in 2009 and personally tracking
down Suzanne Collins to secure the film
rights joining her for The Ballad of
song birds and snakes his fellow Color
Force producer Brad Simpson who has
worked closely with Jacobson on projects
such as the Diary of a Wimpy Kid film
series and the American Crime Story
Anthology series screenwriter Michael
Aunt known for films like Little Miss
Sunshine and Toy Story 3 is also
returning after helping pen the script
for 2013's a Hunger Games Catching Fire
he and fellow screenwriter Michael
Leslie are working from a treatment by
original author Suzanne Collins who is
an executive producer on the project the
h Hunger Games a ballad of song birds
and snakes has been given an MPA rating
of PG-13 which comes as no surprise
given that every previous Hunger Games
movie has earned this rating however as
fans know well things get plenty dark in
panm characters are viciously murdered
and even our noblest heroes are forced
to commit haunting crimes Katniss
herself ends the series by putting a
fatal arrow through president coin
sternum this new outing might take place
in the past but it's not any Rosia the
trailer contains glimpses of all sorts
of of Darkness from a wrathful snow
repeatedly firing a rifle to tributes
attacking each other in the arena I want
my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction it appears as though this
one is going to be the darkest entry in
the franchise yet it's been rated PG-13
for strong violent content and
disturbing material this phrasing is
stronger than that used for previous
centuries which only warned of things
like frightening images and thematic
material to capture the unique setting
of postwar panm in The Hunger Games a
ballad of of song birds and snakes the
production went abroad filming took
place in Poland and Germany across
several locations unlike the Hunger
Games Arenas and the first three films
which were newly designed and built
yearly the 10th Hunger Games took place
in the ruins of an amphi theater these
barebones Arena scenes are filmed at
Centennial Hall in brwa a historic
building made to host events and
concerts additional filming locations
include Berlin's Olympia Stadium a
sports Stadium constructed for the 1936
summer Olympics and the crematorium Bal
shuen V also located in Berlin the
production also made use of the Monument
of the battle of the nations in the
German city of leig Elsewhere in Germany
a public park built on the site of an
abandoned coal and steel production
plant is doubling for District 12 as
unofficial photos from the set appear to
confirm Suzanne Collins The Ballad of
song birds and snakes comes in at 517
pages when you include the epilog making
it the longest book in the series The
Story of young corol Lena Snow's
formative years is divided into four
parts his time as a student at the
capitals Academy being a mentor for the
10th Hunker games becoming a peacekeeper
and then his Reckoning the book's
four-part structure lends itself well to
a two-part movie adaptation the first
part covering the events of The Hunger
Games and a second covering the
aftermath but that won't be the case
instead of splitting the movie into two
parts like they did with McKing J The
Hunger Games a ballad of song birds and
snakes will take on the challenge of
telling its story in a single sitting
i'llbe it's a rather long one the run
time is 165 minutes in the United States
while a slightly shorter version will be
shown in other territories this will
make the Hunger Games a ballot of song
birds and snakes the longest movie in
the series taking the crown from The
Hunger Games Catching Fire The Hunger
Games a ballad of song birds and snakes
takes place 64 years before kiss everine
volunteers as tribute although audiences
are well aware of the origins of The
Hunger Games and Coro lanus Snow's
future the upcoming prequel will offer
deeper insight into the already
established timeline for instance the
10th Hunger Games is the first to
implement mentors for the district's
tributes chosen from the Academy's top
students Additionally the audience
incentives of gambling and purchasing
gifts for tributes that become Main
Stays in future games are implemented
for the first time at the suggestion of
snow everything is about winning if not
the games now than the crowd the film
will also show glimpses into the
devastating War of the first rebellion
and it's immediate after math taking
viewers even further back in the
timeline music plays a crucial role in
The Ballad of song birds and snakes
hence the title Lucy gray B uses her
musical talent to her Advantage as a way
of surviving both The Hunger Games and
day-to-day life in district 12 as
Suzanne Collins explained in an
interview with Scholastic Lucy Gray's
Legacy is that she introduced
entertainment to the Hunger Games she
has several original songs which later
became a part of PanAm history like the
Hanging Tree which was sung by Katniss
and the hung games McKing J part one in
a variety interview Francis Lawrence
described Suzanne Collins as a country
music Al fishon which made finding
Lucy's sound less of a daunting task the
film's music producer Dave carb Drew
from Appalachian music and the creative
team were also influenced by early Dolly
Pon and City SpaceX portrayal of Loretta
Lynn when shaping Lucy her version of
The Hanging Tree can be heard in the
second official trailer according to
Nina Jacobson this song and others are
performed by Rachel zler who opted to
sing them live without playbacks during
filming we also knew that once we had
her on set Rachel really could do it
it's just so easy for her nine time
musar L James Newton Howard is returning
to compose the score as he did for the
previous films in the Hunger gam series
coming back to a franchise 8 years after
its last installment with an entirely
new set of characters can be
intimidating but the creatives behind
the Hunger Games a ballad of song birds
and snakes were up for the challenge
Francis Lawrence told kollider it very
much feels like a Hunger Games movie but
at the same time feels really fresh and
unique and thematically unique as for
the approach of the new characters
Lawrence and Nina Jacobson believe
they're captivating in their own right
when describing Lucy gray bead to
variety Jacobson explained she's such a
different character from Katniss she's
such a performer Katniss is the opposite
this is a woman who loves and lives to
perform what is that dress she's some
sort of clown snow on the other hand
posed some challenges for Lawrence he
explained his thought process to Empire
questioning how do we make this person
that's going to be the antagonist of our
story the protagonist of our story how
can we get audiences behind him in his
struggle and see him change and be
groomed and turned into the snow of the
latest series Lawrence also revealed to
Entertainment Weekly that Tom ble was
advised to refrain from watching early
Donald southernland movies and embrace
his own interpretation of the character
in the literary World readers regard
Suzanne Collins as a highly private
person who rarely participates in
interviews and lacks a social media
presence it's unknown whether she will
expand on the world of PanAm with
another Hunger Games book but she's yet
to dismiss the idea altogether it's just
a matter of finding the right topic and
angle speaking to polygon Nina Jacobson
said that she doesn't think Collins is
done with panm just yet saying do I
think she'll write more books in the
world I do and I hope she will do I have
any idea what they'll be not really it's
mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people bad one thing's for sure
Collins won't write another PanAm set
book just because there's money to be
made Francis Lawrence told Entertainment
Weekly the main reason why he and
Jacobson stand behind her if she chooses
to revisit the series saying Suzanne
always writes for a thematic Foundation
if she has something to say I want to
hear it I'm fascinated by her
perspective I will always want to follow
her
lead